dans un instant dans T PMP vous allez
voir ça va s'enchaîner très très vite et
là nous sommes avec Jean euh qui habite
un village de 1700 habitants c'est ça
c'est ça et vous vivez un enfer euh tir
de mortier passage à tabac insulte
euh ça a commencé quand ça a commencé un
un en 2021 14 juillet 2021 où parce que
je je suis fédérateur j'aime mettre les
gens en connexion parce que je travaill
dans le divertissement on sortait du
covid j'avais pas envie de de me risquer
à attraper cette maladie et donc j'ai
privatisé ma rue avec la cor de la
municipalité qui était au courant ça se
passait bien au départ après c'est
différent et on a réuni les voisins
devant devant devant mon habitation on a
réun les voisins les amis on était une
trentaine et la soirée battait son plein
c'était super très agréable vers 22h30
je reçois un sms d'un numéro que je ne
connais pas assez VM me demandant de
couper la musique pour tapage nocturne
que tous les voisins se plaignent donc
je suis pas un quelqu'un qui cherche les
problèmes je me P je baisse le volume
sonore la musique c'était afroatino c
très Zook salsa Raay regaton donc
forcément peut-être que que ça a excité
le monsieur et et en ayant baissé le
volume sonore 10 minutes après on a reçu
on a une dizaine quinzaine de tirs de
mortier donc on était pleinement visé
c'est les habitations puisque les rues
sont étroites qui nous ont protégé et
donc là la soirée c'est terminé tout le
monde est parti en courant on a tout
replié on s'est mis à l'abri dans mon
garage qui donne sur la rue et toute la
soirée ça a été des caillassages des
insultes pleinement homophobe pleinement
antisémite ça a été le début mais j'ai
voilà c'était j'ai pas pris au on compte
vraiment la gravité des fait c'est mes
amis qui m'ont dit dépose plainte va
déposer plainte c'est grave j'ai d non
il va se calmer lui-même il va l'alcool
va lui dessouler et ça ira mieux
derrière mais en fait non ça ça a été de
pire en pire vous connaissiez les vous
connaissez les auteurs des faits alors
je ne les connais pas je l'ai sûrement
croisé dans le village bonjour au revoir
comme quelqu'un de civilisé mais je n'ai
jamais eu d'interaction autre avec ce
avec ce bonhomme alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe
maintenant ben rien enfin si je veux pas
dire ça une une instruction est en en
cours mais qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé depuis parce que c'est quoi votre
quotidien c'est ça mon quotidien ben
c'est ce que vous voyez sur la voiture
donc je suis pris pour cible
gratuitement ma maison ma voiture c'est
un cauchemar depuis 2021 à la suite de
cette pendant 15 jours entre le 14
juillet 1er août 2021 ça a été des
insultes des lettres avec des des des
croix gamés enfin que je pensais je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi des croix gamés
sur des lettres des insultes en un peu
en tout genre et le premier route je
participe à un videgrenier dans mon
village en tant que participant pour
faire du vide dans ma maison que
j'essaie de vendre parce que la
situation est àubuesque et l'agresseur
du 14 juillet me se fout devant mon
stand en m'insultant donc je détourne le
regard pour pas lui donner du crédit
parce que c'est un monsieur qui est pas
apparemment tout pas toute sa tête et et
donc il se jette sur moi m'attrape au
COLBAC en hurlant que je suis un S juif
un assassin de palestinien que je mérite
de crever enfin des des trucs très très
durs pour moi je me suis laissé faire et
c'est une femme person alors personne a
branché hein il y avait peut-être 200
personnes dans la rue personne a branché
j'étais à 10 m des organisateurs qui se
pavanent ça faisait rire forcément parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'actualité c'est quand
il y a quelqu'un qui est en danger on
rigole et on filme donc personne n'est
intervenu il y a qu'une femme d'une
cinquantaine d'années qui était
exposante qui a fendu la foule pour me
venir en aide donc l'agresseur a changé
de cible il s'en est pris à elle il a
été véhément avec elle des insultes des
menaces de mort et c'est à ce moment-là
que les organisateurs se sont déplacés
pour le calmer en lui expliquant tu le
choperas mais à un autre moment pas ici
pas devant tout le monde donc moi je me
sentend pas en sécurité j'ai été déposé
plaintte le 1er août 2021 ma première
plainte voilà ma première plainte
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis depuis
rien euh le entre entre cette plainte et
euh ça c'est ça s'était calmé j'avais
des cayassages des insultes c'était bref
il y avait pas de de de gravité enfin en
tout cas moi je la voyais pas la gravité
j'ai été dans le déni très longtemps de
la gravité et euh l'homme moi je suis
parti entre-temps dans ma famille en
Bretagne je reviens en début d'année
2022 j'appelle la gendarmerie pour
savoir où en est ma plainte que j'ai
déposé est-ce que l'homme a été
interpellé là on me répond de manière
assez étrange que l'homme a quitté le
village il habite plus dans le village
il a vendu il est parti au centre-ville
de la ville à côté d'iborne donc ils ont
donné le dossier à la police nationale
donc je trouve ça un peu étrange puisque
les faits se déroulent dans le village
que ce soit la police nationale qui n'a
rien à voir avec le village mais bon
admettons je fais confiance et eux les
enquêteurs pas moi et mois de juin je
dépose sur ma façade le drapeau LGBT
drapeau arc-en-ciel en soutien aux
violences faites à travers le monde au
LGBT parce que je me sentais concerné
donc je me dis je vais quand même
montrer mon soutien et alors là ça a été
2022 un cauchemar ça démarré par des
lettres de une lettre en tout cas j'ai
donné à votre équipe la lettre est folle
c'est la moins folle hein c'est la moins
violenteah la letre la lettre est folle
he excusez-moi mais j'ai lu la lettre
elle est incroyable he voilà et donc je
va vous la lire un petit peu bonjour
monsieur
euh vous êtes péd tant mieux pour vous
notre village est un village familial
nous sommes plusieurs voisins si ce
n'est pas tout le village à ne pas
approuver votre drapeau de péd ici ce
n'est pas la Gay Pride et ne sera jamais
trouvez pas ça fou vous c'est voilà ça
reflète un peu la pire c non c'est pas
la pire merci de retirer rapidement ce
drapeau contre nature nos enfants sont
les premiers choqués par votre
provocation ça suffit maintenant retirez
ce drapeau immonde et s'il vous plaît
cassez-vous rentrez d'où vous venez vous
connaissez le dicton qui cherche trouve
cessez immédiatement votre provocation à
la con on ne veut pas de péd
trans tout comme on ne veut pas des
assassins de Palestiniens comme vous car
vous êtes Juifs non fier pas de honte
que votre peuple assassine des innocent
on ne veut pas non plus des ou
bounoules ici c'est un village de
Français qui respecte les lois
le pape soutient nos actions Dieu notre
Créateur est insulté par les gens comme
vous h à vous d'habiter si proche de
l'église vous êtes un individu abject et
salissz notre patrimoine merci de
le camp rapidement de notre joli village
que vous insultez en étant et juif
en plus il n'y a pas de lieu de culte
ici pour vous et notre église ne veut
pas de juiverie péd dernier courrier
avant action le message est-il assez
clair cassez-vous emportez la honte avec
vous sale péd non mais c'est fou c'est
c'est c'est c'est un débile c'est c'est
oui alors je pense pas que ce soit le
village qui soit qu comme ça c'est une
personne qui va gangrainer d'autres
personnes qui veulent enfin c'est assez
dingue cette lettre cette lettre elle
est blindée de faute là elle a bien été
rédigée mais elle est blindé de
moi je me suis dit c'est des gamins ou
des ados qui écoutent leurs parents j'ai
pas déposé plainte pour cette lettre je
l'ai je l'ai prise en photo puis je l'ai
jeté je me dis ça va ça va se calmer et
ça a été un enchaînement alors là alors
bizarrement les les gens du village me
disaient l'individu qui t'a attrapé en
COLBAC au videgrenier il est revenu il
est dans le village attention méfis-toi
comme par hasard alors évidemment il est
présumé innocent parce que j'ai pas de
preuve mais comme par hasard les faits
de violence se sont intensifiés au
moment où cet homme est revenu dans le
village habiter une maison dans laquelle
elle a été vendue ça encore c'est
troublant à ce moment-là moi j'ai quand
même contacté la mairie de mon village
qui m'a reçu le maire m'a très bien reçu
il m'a dit que il est maire qu' peut pas
faire il a pas de pouvoir il a pas le
brason il peut rien faire que si cet
homme était en logement social il
l'aurait foutu à la dégager le village
parce que il est connu pour des
problèmes les personnes qui ont eu des
problèmes des griefes assez lourds avec
cet homme juste une personne dans le
village i alors ça ça part d'une
personne mais cet homme a gangrainé
beaucoup de gens parce qu'il y a
d'autres personnes qui ont été mouillées
dans mon village les personnes qui
connaissent qui savent ne disent rien
tout le monde sait c'est une omerta
violente moi j'ai j'ai du mal avec ça
donc forcément depuis 2021 j'ai mis ma
maison en vente pour quitter cette folie
j'ai eu du mal à la vendre parce que les
gens ne voulaient pas être des cibles à
leur tour puisque ma maison est prise
pour cible donc j'ai eu du mal là je
récemment je viens d'accepter une
proposition d'achat alors forcément je
vends à perte hein mais c'est le prix à
payer parce que sinon z douloureux si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc et il y a eu ça il y a eu puis
après ça a été des lettres beaucoup plus
véhémentes où on me menace de me
décapité on me dit que je suis comme
Samuel paatti je fais de la
provocation bon qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'il y en a eu beaucoup
c'était quasiment tout en
quotidiennement ça été très dur surtout
que moi entreetemps 2021 j'ai eu un
traumatisme crénien très lourd qui a
rien à voir en lien avec les les
agressions mais qui m'a affecté puisque
j'ai des Sécal invisible et irréversible
qui sont très lourdes donc ça m'a
impacté encore plus ma détresse et en
2022 bah j'ai eu alors kayassage vide
brisé pneus crevé les croix gamés dans
l'enquête alors ça je tiens à le dire je
vais peut-être me mettre des gens à dos
mais les gendarmes en charge de cette
enquête m'ont expliqué que ils allaient
requalifier les plaintes au bout de la
9e en harcèlement moral puisque pour eux
les croix gamé n'en sont pas ce sont des
symboles hindou svadiska symbole de pays
d'amour alors effectivement ça a été dit
au téléphone moi j'ai de suite
retranscrit par mail à la gendarmerie
que ça soit écrito qu' a un échange
c'est pas l'ombre d'un doute là sal juif
avec ça voilà crève crève sale juif
votre lettre elle tombe sous le cou de
l'antisme vous qui vous a dit ça c'est
un officier de de
gendarmerie qui m'a dit ça qui est
revenu sur ces dir puisque moi de mon
côté avec l'aide de d'association j'ai
diganté
une liiggn qui a été mandaté après le
monsieur est revenu sur C dire dit vous
avez mal compris au téléphone évidemment
c'est moi qui comprends mal c'est leur
parole c'est eux qui sont ermentés et
pas moi donc délicatement j'ai dû me
soumettre et et c'est vrai que c'est
très délicat parce que par la suite le
maire le maire a été contacté par des
associations je vous ai envoyé
d'ailleurs le mail la réponse du maire
ou des associations LGBT qui a plus
demande à ce que le maire fasse des
appels à témoins condamne sur son site
média et dénonce ce qui m'arrive il a
jamais voulu il a dit non ça ne concerne
qu'une personne pas le village donc non
donc il légitime ce que je subis ce qui
moi je là vous allez partir du village
ah oui ça y est je je quitte parce que
je peux plus c'est la folie he ma maison
est prisepible ma voiture elle
esttilé ma voiture vous dormez toujours
là-bas là
je dors toujours là-bas mais je suis
alors si je peux citer des associations
qui m'ont soutenu énormément comme SOS
Homophobie ils ont fait mettre ma maison
en sécurité énormément merci ils m'ont
posé l'alarme et la vidéo enfin l'alarme
et la vidé surveillance pour me mettre
en sécurité parce que parce que parce
que j'étais en danger je je suis pas
violent mais je me dis qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que je passe que je fasse peur
peut-être moi aussi vous avez déposé
plusieurs plantes oui y en a eu
peut-être 19 en tout ah ou mi bout à
bout là il y a une instruction qui est
en cours la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'un
juge d'instruction enfin me me va me
convoquer début 2024 où je vais pouvoir
en espérant cerner les gens mais j'ai
été tabassé dans un gapan à plusieurs
reprises hein pas qu'une fois ahoui par
combien de personnes alors ils étaient
trois le le getapant en septembre 2022
ils étaient trois mais après j'ai des
gens qui m'attendaient cagoulet devant
ma porte qui me mettaient des coups de
PO dans la tronche je porortais pas
plainte parce que j'étais dans le déit
vraiment de la gravité je voulais pas
être une
victime je voulais pas être une victime
je voulais pas être faible je voulais
pas montrer que j'étais faible et puis
les médias de la région s'en sont m'ont
contacté m'ont dit on va vous aider on
va médiatiser ça a été l'horreur parce
que je suis je suis passé à visage
découvert je pensais j'ai fait confiance
en fait il cherchait le buzz avoir leur
nom en mod article c'est tout et j'ai
été attrapé dans un quéapant tabassé bon
j'ai fait des des bêtises parce que j'ai
voulu en finir c'était horrible de de de
et en fait je me suis battu seul contre
tous les gens qui savent ne veulent pas
parler les témoins qui voulaient j'ai
des captures d'écran j'ai tout donné en
gendarmerie donc les gens qui qui
étaient prêts à témoigner ah non on nous
a mis en garde la mairie nous ont dit de
N taire on doit rien enfin c'est
l'omerta total personne ne veut parler
tout le monde me laisse crever en fait
votre histoire il folle tous les gens
qui vous suivent aujourd'hui à 20h28 qui
réagissent disent cette histoire est
complètement folle et une fois de plus
c'est la victime qui doit partir et qui
doit quitter le village et qui doit
vendre à perte sa maison il y a quand
même un gros gros problème avec les
institutions excusez-moi de vous dire ça
mais là là là il y a un énorme souci
genan donc vous allez partir oui je pars
le plôt possible les cartons sont tous
prêts he c'est quand la dernière
agression que vous avez subi la dernière
agression bah la dernière agression
c'est la nuit qui était sensible où il y
avait un appel à tué les juges de France
ma voiture j'avais une amie qui était à
mon domicile pendant une semaine en
vacances et ma voiture a été pare-brise
a été cassé les croix gamés les pneus
crevés bon après là où où j'en veux un
peu aussi enfin où j'en veux indirement
c'est que les gensarmes n'ont jamais
pris les empreintes sur mon véhicule il
a fallu que soit la police national qui
pour une fois là récemment prennent les
empreintes pour essayer de trouver les
auteurs après les gendarmes ils ont fait
une enquête hein je dis pas qu'ils ont
pas fait leur travail ils ont fait leur
travail mais à mes yeux peut-être pas
assez puisque parce que l'auteur des
faits n'est toujours enfin jamais ét
Inter c'est surtout ça alors qu'il y a
des témoins qui ont été auditionnés des
témoins qui sont prêts à parler
d'ailleurs les témoins faut que je vous
le dise alors je vais me mettre tout le
village à dos et c'est pas grave c'est
déjà fait déjà depuis un moment mais
tous les rares témoins quatre personnes
qui m'ont soutenu devant les gendarmes
et devant les journalistes ont été pris
à parti également et ont dû quitter le
village ils ont vendu leur maison sont
partis et voilà donc je suis tout seul
maintenant dans mon village face à la
folie c'est fou c'est fou je dis pas que
c'est tout le village c'est quo c'est
quoi le profil des personnes qui qui
vous agressent al il la cinquantaine
cinquantaine ouais quand quand je suis
passé dans les médias locaux j'ai été
agressé à visage découvert par des gens
qui étaient 50 60 c'est pas des jeunes
c'est pas c'est pas des jeunes il y a eu
des jeunes puisqu'on m'a fait le salut
nazi avec la phrase on m'a sorti des
trucs assez c'est des gens du village
que vous connaissez moi moi moi je
connais pas parce que je travaille dans
le divertissement donc j'étais
saisonnier à l'extérieur j'étais là que
rarement dans ma maison mais c'est des
gens oui qui ont qui on forcément qui
m'ont connu qui qui m'ont connu moi je
me cache pas j'ai une étoile j'ai Magan
David j'ai une étoile de David quand on
me demande est-ce que tu es juif je dis
bah oui chez l'étoile de David j'en suis
fier je vais pas la cacher cétait
rappelé que les auteurs des fait ne sont
pas musulmans ça c ils sont pas
musulmans faut pas qu' comment 19 plein
de séri 19 pleinou in merci oui Gill ce
qui est incroyable c'est que personne
vous a vraiment aidé ni même écouté le
maire le député les la police la
gendarmerie comment vous expliquez ça
moi j'ai une explication c'est que ceux
qui vous adressent sont protégés est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
complètement oui je suis complètement
d'accord avec ça bien sûr et pour
information euh le en décembre dernier
donc décembre 2022 la personne qui m'a
sorti des griffes de l'agresseur pendant
la elle a été contactée par la
gendarmerie pour être mise en
confrontation avec l'agresseur donc elle
c'est une femme qui est seule qui a très
peur elle a dit je n'ai pas le à être
confronté avec ce mec c'est un malade il
est dangereux il sait où j'habite je ne
veux pas et les gendarmes ils ont dit
mais pas du tout il est devant nous il
est très gentil in offensif vous pouvez
venir sans crainte donc là je lui ai dit
B il y a une subordination de témoins
c'est pas possible on essae de de
l'influencer donc elle a elle a elle
elle vend son bien elle s'en va elle
veut quitter le coin elle est inquiète
et les journal anal de France 3 Lang de
crusillon ou Occitanie je sais pas quand
ils sont venus m'interviewer le 19
décembre dernier 2022 ont été les
témoins alors là on peut pas dire que
c'est moi qui a fabule où j'ai été pris
à parti par plusieurs personnes à visage
découvert devant les journalistes menace
de mort ins antisémite les journalistes
ils en vevenaient pas ils étaient
choqués ils m'ont dit à visage découvert
ah mais c'est grave e mec c'est grave
c'est très grave protégé par qui c'est
très grave aussi 20 minutes qui discute
c'est qui qui le protège l'omerta du
village 19 exactement c'est dans les
villages ça le problème des problèmes
comme ça dans les villages Pierre Jean
excusez-moi on espère que votre histoire
va bouger et vous allez pouvoir être
enfin heureux mais en tout cas déjà ce
qu'il y a c'est que vous déménagez c'est
ça ça me rend fou parce que c'est vous
qui êtes obligé de partir de votre
village merci en tout cas pour votre
témoignage merci d'avoir été là allez
chéri on va passer
maintenant on va passer maintenant à la
page P avec miram Palomba qui arrive
dans un instant on a des nouvelles de de